And I'm going to compare the Marxist theory of suffering to the Judeo Christian
theory of suffering and the Judeo Christian would be.
And the reason I'm doing that is because I think the Judeo Christian theory of
suffering is actually one of the foundation stones of our entire culture.
And so it actually matters why you think they're suffering.
And so the story that describes the entry of suffering into the world,
that mythological story is the story in Genesis,
the story of Adam and eve.
And basically what happens in the story of Adam and Eve is Adam and eve are
unconscious to begin with.
And they're sort of in this paradise will state there's no death or at least
there's no knowledge of death.
There's also no knowledge of self.
And then eve eats the apple that the serpent gives her and the scales fall from
her eyes and she gives the apple to Adam and he eats it as well.
So she makes him self conscious.
They both wake up.
The first thing that happens is they realize that they're naked and they cover
themselves up.
And the second thing that happens as a consequence of that realization is that
they come to know the difference between good and evil and I mean that's a
insanely complicated story that's dealing with a re absolutely incomprehensible
number of complex phenomena simultaneously but it basically goes something like
this is that to be aware that you're naked is to be aware of your fragility and
your mortality.
When when you have a nightmare about being naked in front of a crowd,
it means that you're exposed to the crowd,
all your flaws,
all your mortal vulnerability is exposed to the crowd for for for them to see,
for you to be ashamed of for them to judge.
That's partly why we're all close.
That's partly why human being human.
Why clothing is a human universal.
There's many human universals by the way,
clothing is one of them although it's used for many different purposes so Adam
and eve cover themselves up and so because they've realized that they're,
that they're vulnerable,
they're naked and vulnerable.
That self consciousness,
human beings are self conscious animals.
We're really the only self conscious animals.
Other animals have the glimmerings of self consciousness.
Some of them can identify themselves in a mirror for example,
but we have whole theories of ourselves.
We have whole articulated verbal and philosophical theories of what a human
being is and what we each are as individuals.
So really those aren't in the same conceptual universe.
It's a whole different,
it's a qualitatively different issue.
In the case of human beings were self conscious,
self consciousness,
loads on trait neuroticism technically speaking which means that self
consciousness is primarily something that manifest itself in the form of
negative emotion and we all know that you're on stage,
you get self conscious.
Is that a good thing?
No,
you can give so self conscious that your tongue tied,
right?
It's not good.
You don't want to be self conscious on stage or maybe ever you get self
conscious in the,
in the face of someone you're trying to impress.
He turned all red.
You Stammer.
It's like self consciousness is a rough business and it's no wonder because you
know yourself for the f for the fragile fool that you are,
and it's even worse than that because see,
it took me a long time to figure out why it was that when Adam and eve woke up,
they also develop the knowledge of good and evil.
I just couldn't figure that out because it didn't make sense to me what,
how selfconsciousness knowledge of vulnerability and the knowledge of good and
evil we're tangled together or even really what the knowledge of good and evil
meant.
But I figured it out eventually I thought,
oh,
I get it.
It was like a real revelation to me.
As soon as you know you're vulnerable,
you know the difference between good and evil.
Because as soon as you know you're vulnerable,
then you know everyone else is.
And as soon as you know that everyone else is vulnerable,
you know how to hurt them.
And so that means you consciously know how to bring suffering into big,
and that's the knowledge of good and evil.
And you know that because let's say that you're really good at torturing people,
hadn't,
there's no doubt a number of people in the audience who are actually quite good
at that,
and maybe you all have a bit of an affinity for it.
Um,
if you're married,
I'm sure your partner would testify to that.